hello welcome to this episode of not too
deep I'm your host Grace and a Helbig
but first tonight today this afternoon
whenever you're listening or watching
this we have a very exciting episode for
you Amanda
Stanton is here you might know her from
The Bachelor from bachelor in paradise
she's got a new book out she's a single
mom she's got a clothing line she's
ruling the world right now and she also
has the most calming energy and I feel
like I was very aggressively asking her
too many questions this episode either
way I think we had a great time enjoy
this episode of not too deep for the man
to Stanton pairing your great idea into
a reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're showcasing your
work or selling products of any kind
they have beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can easily make a beautiful
website by yourself if you get stuck you
can go to Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support they're
there to help head to Squarespace comm
such grace for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain Amanda
thank you for being here yeah thanks for
having me of course this is very
exciting
I have to ask you the first question
yeah are you going to stagecoach next
year okay I love stagecoach and I've
gone for years like even before I was on
the show I got a stagecoach and then all
this happened and so I was talking about
it with some of my friends that we go
every year we're like we can't go next
year well I really you guys all have to
absolutely go next year like so people
are gonna be upset if you guys don't
show up next year I think we're gonna
plan like a Cabo trip or something
instead I mean yeah Cabo the next
stagecoach further south okay for people
that don't know who you are and what you
do I asked this question to a lot of
guests what's your deal so I was on The
Bachelor about three and a half years
ago in a single mom
I was on vens season season 20 because
we didn't watch it and then I went on to
do bachelor in paradise
I did season 3 and then I went back and
did season 4
so I've done three seasons of bachelor
shows Wow
yeah okay how what was your first
auditioning process for the show like
how does that where I'm a like recently
into bachelor bachelor paradise the
whole franchise I miss been season so I
think I started right after that but
what's that whole like vetting process
it's crazy so I mean I think everyone
kind of gets casted in different ways
they have open casting calls that you
can go to people yeah people will send
in videos of themselves trying to get
casted for me my mom actually nominated
me your mom and I have no idea until I
started having calls from the show and I
was like is this a joke this I think
this is sweet but you don't know I was
like are my friends playing it I thought
it was a prank phone call like who did
this but then I ended up just coming up
since I'm local I live in Orange County
their offices in LA so I drove up and
did a couple interviews with them and
then once they get down to like a
hundred people you go to this crazy
casting weekend where you have to go
through all this testing they tested for
STDs you go through for real oh yeah you
go through like all this psychology
testing you answer like 5,000 questions
about yourself Wow
intense you basically have a giant like
a group retreat therapy session
basically yeah but you don't get to see
any of the results thank you and you
don't get to see anyone else it's there
you're like locked away in a hotel room
Wow yeah it's very intense so that's the
craziest thing to me like I'm obsessed
with my phone I'm obsessed with social
media and I think the thing that is
always so fascinating on those shows is
the reminder that you guys are
completely oblivious to everything
that's happening in the world everything
we don't have our phones we don't have
TV sometimes they'll let you bring a
book but you have to show them and they
have to say it's okay this is like some
weird summer camp isolated but it's
weird cuz at first you're like this is
gonna be so hard without my phone right
but you get so used to it and then you
have this moment and everyone says it
when you're on the show
you're like without your phone for X
amount of time and everyone's like this
makes me realize like when I get home I
don't need to be on my phone as much
she's gonna say did that condition you
at all when you got home my phone I can
go all this time without it like why am
I on it so much as soon as I got home I
was like back on not too much okay
missed it
yeah but it's like I know that you can
you can live without it so but so you're
sequestered basically in this situation
you have no phone you have no like
access to the outside world and also
you're literally learning how to talk to
humans like all day long just like what
do you do for like what how much
downtime do you have and like what are
you doing with that downtime we have a
lot of downtime I'm sure and so yeah you
don't have your phone and like sometimes
they'll let you take a nap they want you
up uh-huh so it's like what do you do
when you're waking up at 6:00 in the
morning and you know you don't have TV
you don't have anything so we would make
up like the weirdest games like the
weirdest stuff like what kind of games
we play this game called the vegetable
game have you ever played it nope you
sit around in a circle and everyone's a
different vegetable have to eat what you
can't use your lips after calculated
okay and then like everyone has to like
go around and like say everybody's
vegetable name it sounds crazy you would
play it for hours it was like yeah
producer of the show like roll the
camera this is the best thing they did
but like you know they never aired it
cuz it wasn't theirs no juicy enough
yeah exactly you're getting along we
can't yeah it was funny though we did
some weird stuff but so that's so bunker
so now you're part of bachelor nation
mmm this and like this insane community
for better or worse yeah what's that
like like it seemed so nuts to be like
thrust into this world where a lot of
people are very invested in your story
yeah so I feel like it's something you
kind of know before you go on the show
but if you like
don't really know what it's gonna be
like until after you can't really
prepare yourself sure I'm sure you can
fundamentally understand that yeah is
gonna happen but like how can you
possibly prepare yeah so I mean yeah I
mean it was like a big lifestyle change
for me but it's also cool because you go
on the show and you meet so many new
people and they're really the only
people that went through that experience
with you so you become super close with
them it's like you're almost like
sisters more than friends it's kind of
clear things are already fraternity yeah
kind of thing yeah and you know you can
have a friend that you won't see for
like five years then you see them and
it's like nothing ever happened you know
and that's kind of how it is when I see
like anyone from the show that I was on
a season with it's like we're just
automatically friends for life yeah
absolutely I mean I exist in the YouTube
world and it's the same thing when I see
how their content creators that I maybe
have maybe never met before but I feel
like I know them and it's just that
familiar like seeing someone yeah you
just have like a weird bond with them
because they get you do you because you
guys are so transparent because you put
everything out there do you have fan
encounters or people come up to you on
the street that know every I mean your
publicist literally nodding her head
like people that truly feel like they're
it's so invested in your your world and
your journey yeah I feel like it's kind
of like it never was weird to me I guess
yeah like having someone come up and be
like how arkinson char like how's the
new house or anything I feel like people
know a lot but it's almost nice it's
like easy to have conversation with
people and they already know everything
in office I think it's cute it's nice
and so also I think it's very rare to be
you know a mom on the show yeah how old
are your daughters they're seven and
five now okay I was on the show a while
ago so they were baby I mean Charlie was
like a baby when I was on the show so do
they understand at all like what's
happening now so I feel like for them
it's like kind of all they know cuz oh
yeah you know Charlie was so young so
she just kind of grew up knowing that
you know people might recognize this is
normal behavior sometimes people come up
to my mom and they know her yeah and
it's funny too because
they go to their dad's house every other
weekend and like sometimes people will
recognize them when I'm not around
oh really yeah which is funny and
they're always like Oh mom someone at
the gym came up to us and I'm like yeah
so yeah I feel like they're used to it
they kind of get it kins definitely gets
it more than Charlie yeah tries to watch
a show I don't let her oh yeah I was
gonna say you have parameters yeah I
will let them watch it really no ever
maybe I mean someday and it's very
close-up kissing yeah so what okay so
now you have this book out that is half
a life style guide
yeah half like a memoir situation what
was that process like because you spill
your guts on TV all the time and then
writing this book I'm sure it's like a
different form of spilling your guts
yeah it was kind of like therapeutic
writing it but I started it I would say
over two years ago or about two years
ago oh wow it's been a really long
process but it was such a long process
that it got to the point where I like
almost forgot that like this is actually
gonna be out and available for like
everybody else to read it's probably
more intimate of an experience to have
someone buy the book than to see you on
television it is yeah and I talk a lot
about like my life before the show and
that's kind of what made me want to
write a book in the first place it was
that after I was on the show I had so
many single moms reaching out to me
asking me for advice or just telling me
that you know they could relate to me
and it kind of made me want to write a
book mainly to help with single moms out
there but then I'd also learned so much
from the show I was like well I think I
have something that you know every girl
can relate to yeah
so that's kind of wearing well with it
but so what's the major piece of advice
life advice that you focus on in the
book if there's one I would say it's
just kind of about you know making
mistakes and figuring yourself out and
being confident being alone at the end
of the day mmm yeah because there's a
lot in I can I try to imagine what it
would be like to be in a situation like
that to be in a show like that to be in
to be on display and that way and to be
vulnerable and raw in front of
the world yeah and I'm sure makes you
build up walls and boundaries in
different ways and I'm sure you learned
so much about yourself through this
insane process totally the is there a
camaraderie in everyone else that's on
the show in terms of like I can't
believe we've all gone through this
experience together like that you have
been so grown vulnerable on TV in such a
way yeah so it's funny because you like
when you watch the show you're like
these people are so like emotional but
in reality like I think it's because
like we talked about earlier like we
don't have our phones we're right we
don't have like any of our friends and
family from home no TVs nothing so it's
like all of your support systems are
gone yeah and you're just really wrapped
up in everything that's going on plus
you know we're kind of sleep-deprived
oh yeah and we're drinking a lot and so
there's a lot of things that go into it
but yeah like it just makes you really
open up and talk about your emotions and
like dig deep into things that have
happened to you and stuff that you
wouldn't normally talk about and I feel
like you kind of sticks with you after
the show to like I feel like I'm a lot
better about talking about how I feel I
was gonna ask the way you communicate
like emotions and the way that you talk
because obviously we all know like
producers feed you lines and you guys
use the word journey all the time I'm
amazing and amazing and I can see myself
getting there I can't see myself getting
there do you find yourself having those
sort of that sort of rhetoric with like
everyday life no but I will say it's
like it's helped you know like we you
talk about your feelings more and I have
like you know a lot of people there on
the show will say that too they're like
oh I'm so much more comfortable talking
about my feelings but it's not as
intense as on when you're on the show no
one's grilling you constantly to be like
and how did you feel about this yeah
what about this exact moment and what
about this moment and what about this
thing totally yeah there has there been
a biggest regret I I like I always
answer this question it's like so cheesy
and I'm like well I can't regret
anything sure because I'm happy with
where I'm at now
but I mean I definitely think I you know
made some mistakes I mean that's par for
the course
yeah that's being a human being totally
deep would you go to another season I
would not know you're out I'm Mexican
I'm retired what so you're you were on
two seasons of bachelor in paradise yeah
what brought you back for the second
season so I think kind of what we just
talked about I think there was a lot of
things my first time around where I kind
of knew maybe I wasn't making all the
right choices sure did it anyways
because I was hoping for the best and
then it didn't work out and I was like
oh shoot like I wasted my time like
doing something I knew wasn't right so
I'm gonna go back and give it another
shot yeah didn't really work out for me
that time either but also you know I had
like certain memories there wasn't gonna
go create new ones I mean I'm glad I did
it yeah yeah I mean you feel like yeah
you don't want that to be all for naught
so come back and see what happens again
yeah it's like every time I go into a
casino I go back and I say yeah I'm
gonna fit and put all this money down
again and see what happens it's so funny
that's exactly exactly what it was like
for me so what do you do outside I mean
this also must be so bizarre to be part
of this community and so what do you do
outside of bachelor in paradise like
we're outside of just bachelor nation in
general like how do you separate from
that so I feel like I have kind of
separated myself from it in a sense just
because I have kids me like have a
pretty high way so it's like yeah like
my life's changed a lot but it's also
stayed the same and a lot of ways to
yeah look like a pretty normal life you
know they go to school I'm the class mom
for Kinsley's class and that's great
yeah I'm a dance mom you're a dance mom
yeah
are you into Dance Moms the actual
television show I never watched it but
my kids are obsessed really obsessed on
YouTube and like that's their dream it's
to be on yeah they want to be an Abby
Lee Miller's pyramid they do and it's
funny cuz Ken's a super sensitive like
she has one teacher that's like barely
strict Oh Kenz will like cry and she's
like I'm never going back but she wants
to be on that team I'm like I'm pretty
sure that teacher who's like gonna make
you cry every day
that's her mo is to make people cry I
don't know if you're ready for that yet
but it's like yeah it's her dream so
okay so they have like full
personalities your donors then yeah and
do so they're in dance do they want to
be an entertainment in that world
not really so kids definitely has a
personality for it she wants to do
acting classes and all that but we have
very like my personality is very
different than theirs okay so it's funny
kins is like a huge personality or
Charlie I'd sees a little bit more like
me I think quieter more laid-back yeah
yeah do you want them to be taking
acting classes and doing and pursuing
that world uh so I mean I don't
necessarily want them to be I'm not sure
yeah but I mean if kids wants to do like
acting class she wants to do drama and
stuff like that yeah I'm like that's
what you want to do then to go for it
supportive mom yeah there also must be
and I can't imagine I don't have
children I have a dog same thing kind of
very close she's very dramatic yeah the
you must get so much feedback online
good and bad about being a mom in this
world I can't imagine what that feels
like
constantly yeah I'm sure people are like
you're wagging fingers like this is the
wrong thing to do I can't believe this
yeah it's like every little thing like
no matter what I do it's like someone
criticized like it but I kind of
realized that's just how social media is
in general I mean I think it's worse
when you're a mom yeah sure but it's
like really with anything yeah so how do
you how do you girls feel about this
book tour about you like opening up in
this book and being so like raw so they
don't really know okay they're like a
little too young I mean they know
because I was traveling last week for it
so they're like oh you know I think
mom's doing work yeah they know I wrote
a book but they like it's funny they
haven't even asked like oh can I read it
like nothing haven't even asked so I
feel like in this era that they're like
if it's not available on my phone
immediately I don't know how to handle
exactly it's like it's very Youtube
version yeah can i watch
this on my phone do you is it available
on audiobook it's about to be okay I
don't know the exact date but it's
coming out but I just recorded it so
yeah you recorded it so what was that
process like cuz reading back everything
must be so much more intense than just
sitting and writing it down yeah and
also I had never read my book start to
finish
oh yeah so you're reading it for the
first time yeah so it was a lot and it
was a lot of talking by the end of the
day I was like no one talked to me but
it was fun I got it done in just a
couple days so it should be coming out
hopefully in like the next month yes I
think I've enjoyed this podcast goes up
I think it should be out by then we're
gonna assume that okay we run on the
sumption z-- here yes really yeah okay
we're gonna take a quick break and when
we get back I have more questions for
you and then we have a bunch of Twitter
questions so we'll be right back with
more not too deep oh we got another
support from Squarespace this episode -
in your dreams into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project I'm
talkin you want to start a new business
you want to showcase your work you're a
published content you want to sell
products or more they are the tool for
you they have beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks so you can easily make
a beautiful website all by yourself they
also have a powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and they have analytics
that help you grow your site in real
time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get the help you need with
their 24/7 award-winning customer
support Squarespace empowers millions of
people from designers to lawyers artists
to gamers even restaurants and gyms to
turn their great ideas into something
real so go to squarespace.com slash
grace for a free trial when you're ready
to launch use the offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain again that's
Squarespace
calm slash Grace offer code grace deep
as the creators of clean beauty
bareMinerals is driven by a philosophy
that makeup and skin care should make
your skin better not just better looking
and that's why their best-selling
original foundation is made with only
five ingredients guess what they're all
minerals for bare minerals to be clean
without compromise means good for skin
formulas with proven performance so
upgrade to clean beauty products use the
foundation finder at bare minerals calm
to find your perfect match and get 20%
off when you use the promo code not too
deep bare minerals the power of good ok
we are back so you're on book tour
currently yeah how is that going so far
it's good ok been a lot like really long
days right fine and yeah it's been good
is the response from the audience
different than people just coming up
because of the show ah yeah cuz I mean
it most the time it's like they read
well
actually it's funny cuz some of my my
book just came out so there's a lot of
people that'll meet that like half my
book but haven't read it yet right right
right
um but those who have read it it's nice
because it's like oh I didn't know that
you did this or they can relate in
certain ways so I guess it's a little
different than people just coming up to
me because they saw me on the show yeah
the okay
also you gave an exclusive excerpt on
Nick Vilas podcast which I'm very bummed
that we didn't get the exclusive excerpt
oh good
do so you guys all know each other
through the show like you said so like
when you see each other at events it's
like meeting a familiar friend yeah
when is your podcast coming out hey I
don't have a podcast coming out but I
love being guests on podcast I could do
it every week it's the most fun it's so
fun that I don't think I could do my own
okay so what outside of bachelor and all
of that world what do you watch oh gosh
I don't really watch TV really no and
what do you do you like the rice they
don't really watch the boat
well because I would do a watch I mean I
watch Netflix sometimes you're like a
good documentary I'm a big like true
crime person oh yes yeah I'm listening
to a podcast about the Zodiac killer and
it's keeping me up at night like crazy
what podcast is it it's a monster okay
yeah there's a bunch of good like crime
podcasting did you listen to Big Time
but I love Dateline like every Friday is
my favorite been for years yeah it's
terrifying but I'm also addicted yeah
it's like I saw meme about it the other
day I was like isn't it sad that you can
like watch six hours of like crime
documentaries and then just go sleep
goodnight oh my gosh but those are my
favorite is the crime stuff and then I
don't know just movies
I wish I was a TV person I try what do
you do outside of being a mom like for
how do you relax how you like what's
your day like so I've been traveling a
lot this summer right so mainly just
travel and then now that I'm home I'm
trying not to travel much because I'm
just happy to be home
and we're like house hunting right now
is hopefully be moving soon role but
it's a I also have a clothing line yes
so like on that a lot - okay talk about
that world that was was that before the
bachelor or is that like Africa okay
yeah so it just launched in March it's
called Lonnie the label okay how did
that come into fruition so ever since I
had kids like when they were young
babies I'd like loved dressing us up and
like matching oh you guys your Instagram
is goddang adorable thing yeah you
curate a very beautiful family yeah I
loved it and so as they could be so fun
to have my own line mm-hmm so you know I
just started it back in March or just
launched back in March but it's
something that I've been working on for
a couple years you talk about this so
casually as if decided and I did it wait
so how so you wanted to create a
clothing line and then you started
reaching out to people and just kind of
it all came together yeah so we actually
had a company that we partnered with it
reached out to me okay
um a while ago and we had you know gone
back and forth working with a couple
different companies and then we finally
chose one that was just the best fit
there now
lay okay so they helped me with the
designs and the manufacturing the
customer service they do all like my
photo shoots and stuff like that so we
just work together so it's really divine
and makes it a little easier to have
some help ya know for sure how do you
find the inspiration for your designs
mostly just through I mean through
everything my kids are like actually a
huge part of the design process but
we're super picky with their clothes so
I have them help me because I want them
to like wearing the stuff that I make
yeah so they'll help me are just places
I travel things that I wear that make
that I feel good in its kind of where I
was going with it no that's very mean
that's kind of the best part of creating
that sort of business is that you
selfishly do it for yourself exactly I
was like eh what I want to be able to
wear these pieces all the time if it's
not something that I want to wear I
don't want to come out with it yeah so I
pretty much live in everything that I
make so this launched in March how has
it been launching something like that
because I feel like that world is
supersaturated yes it's intimidating to
even begin to do it is so I started
doing kids clothes too so I feel like
that kind of sets it apart a little
because before I was always looking for
cute matching stuff for me and the girls
and it was hard to find something that
was cute for them but that I also would
wear yeah that's true yeah well who does
anything like that yeah so everything's
super cute for adults and then I make
kid versions that are also really cute
for kids that's good yeah that's very
it's also a very like specific market
that I feel is maybe underserved but I
have no idea because I don't exist it's
really hard to find like cute kids
clothes like mommy and me I guess style
yeah it's hard also it feels like
they're in the prime age where they're
still gonna let you do that and then
they're gonna get into the age where
they're like I'm not dressing like you
yeah and they still love it right now
like kids get so excited to match with
me and she certainly yeah that's thank
you yeah she doesn't make me put makeup
on to drop her off at school so she's
like starting to get embarrassed of me
wait she makes you put makeup on she
wants you to look your best when you're
dropping her off at school yeah so like
if I go to drop her off at school and
like sweatpants and no makeup she'll be
like and she'll she says it's so nicely
- she's like
suck them up to me and I Kagamine big
mom are you gonna put a little makeup on
he dropped me off and like do you want
me to she's like yeah so yeah it's like
so sweetly hurtful so sad yeah but so
she's like starting to get a little
embarrassed of me but still likes to
March with me and so that's me
maybe it's it's a backhanded compliment
but she thinks you're you have so much
potential it's so funny or like I'll
wear sweat pants she's like you're
wearing those again like yeah I see
that's very fun you guys all work with
revolve yeah this is what I've noticed
everyone in bachelor nation seems to
work with revolve how does this happen
um it's funny because they actually
reached out to me not that long after I
was on been season and I remember like
the first email that I got from revolve
I was like this is so cool I've made it
benchmark yeah I was like so stoked but
yeah they're they do a lot of like
influencer trips and Coachella and right
they're a fun company to work with but I
think yeah like I think they work with a
lot of influencers a lot of them which
come off the bachelor it seems like so
yeah no I mean that's I feel like
Coachella and stagecoach are sponsored
by revolve yes it's so nuts
what are those trips like for you guys
it's fun I would say like its a mix
between fine and also taking a lot of
photos right I'm like your camera will
must have a million my so I can be like
a little stressful sometimes cuz you're
like okay I want to have fun and enjoy
this but I also have to make sure you
get like X amount of photos yeah
so it's yeah it can be a little
stressful at times but they're super fun
I just went to Canada with them cool a
couple weeks ago and it was amazing so
they do really fun trips and yeah I mean
yeah they're creating a whole culture
around their brand that's yeah super
cool how do you curate your Instagram
photos so do you take you higher
photography just selfishly wanting tips
I have to do it okay so I have
I have a lot of friends that are hey I
really hate using more influencer but
you know it was same but it's okay
you're in a safe space it's okay um and
I don't know I think I used to be a lot
pickier with what I posted I was like
everything has to have the same like
vibe colors and all this I kind of like
gave up on that I take all my photos in
my iPhone I kind of just post whatever I
want that to me seems like the best way
to do it yeah even though I still look
at everyone's feeds and I'm like this
looks beautifully curated yeah so I used
to like try and strive for that but it
was just too hard a table like the
cutest photo but it didn't match with
the rest of my photos and I was like I
can't play now like it's yeah yeah I
just couldn't keep up it was too much so
I gave up you freed yourself I did how
do you filter your photos so I use
Lightroom yeah I do yeah
so I usually I have a set of presets
okay and so I'll use those they work
with most photos but if it doesn't work
then I'll just have to like manually
manage and I'm still working on that
like I don't know how to do any of it I
downloaded a couple presets and they
look crazy
I'm like I don't know how to help this
your skin's like orange you're literally
this yeah exactly
yeah it takes some practice I'm still
not that great at it I have to go back I
need to download more presets that's
what I'm gonna spend my money I'll tell
you my presets please do actually the
ones that I have my they're called the
summertime presets they're actually the
best ones that I've used and I had
another person and I like my other sets
are good but like you know they work
with certain kinds of photos my
summertime ones everyone like everyone
loves up and they're really good it
feels like cuz you guys all in the whole
like I go to the deep dive after
episodes of The Bachelor and I like
check in on everyone and see what
everyone's up to yeah I'm see if
everyone still friends in real life
who's pregnant who's standing who's what
yeah and it feels like you guys all
create these like very beautifully
crafted photos that I'm like they must
all talk and they must all know and
figure this out together
no yeah we accidentally are beautiful
and know how to do this it's a preset
I gotta get it I gotta get it okay so
you grew up in Orange County
yes okay I'm obsessed with Real
Housewives of OC obviously yeah do you
know any of them personally I don't
remember I don't want you to be but I
wish I did because I've seen so many of
them out in the real world yeah
as my friends will say like oh that's so
and so from Real Housewives or like I've
met a couple of them but I don't I can't
like put a personality short show but
I'm I admit I think I've met pretty much
I would say almost all of them yeah they
all they hang out like be cool be cool
regular spots that they hang out in if
you ever want to go oh my gosh okay yeah
I'm just gonna go stalk them out this
hotel in Newport it's called Lido house
and there's this rooftop up there and
it's usually always at least one
housewife there oh my god yeah okay
can't wait can't wait to be the creepy
waiting for a housewife to walk in
what's it like growing up in Orange
County so I was born and raised there
right oh I know and yeah I mean I think
it's a great place to like to raise a
family it's quiet uh-huh it's like a lot
less a lot more boring than LA okay I
feel like it's that's kind of what it is
like a less populated version of LA but
also like we have Laguna Beach we have
the hills we have all this I'm from New
Jersey so watching these shows it paints
a very specific picture of this area do
you think that's accurate not really
really yeah no I mean a little bit but I
feel like that's not that's not
everything like for watching like The OC
I mean I would say it's a lot different
than that okay yeah I still I mean it's
still way more Beauty made a I mean
we've Jersey Shore so that yeah I used
to watch Jersey Shore and I loved it and
if you asked me that question I'd be
like yeah it's that's yeah it is I mean
but everyone's affectation like their
accents are all like very Long Island
yeah very Staten Island in New Jersey
are you from South Jersey like okay
actually closer to Philadelphia so much
more of like a Eagles Philadelphia a
whole situation going on yeah I was in
New Jersey like we could
but in Ridgewood yeah and it's so nice
Ridgewood is beautiful its second right
where I went to college and it's it is
too pretty to represent the rest of the
state very quaint yeah I was like I feel
like I'm in like North Carolina or
something yeah isn't everything
oh yeah there's old school home yeah
it's not all like that in New Jersey not
at all tiny little sneak peek that's
really nice that's so funny
what's your okay so social media has
become like something that is part of
your business part of your world now
what's your go-to social media when you
pick up your phone because you seem like
you have a very balanced relationship
with like a real life life and also
being online yeah I would say Instagram
for sure okay I mean I used to use
Twitter a lot more I don't use it as
much now
not on tik-tok yep my kids are tick tock
I do not yeah we just had a tick tock
sensation record the nepo soap before
bed really I do still don't understand
it what I'd like me to listen to that
episode is I don't know I learned
nothing but I heard a lot I think it may
be that be hardly the best way that's
how I would describe it but I yeah
absolutely no idea I don't really
understand it who is your go to follow
on Instagram like who are you checking
in on regularly um how do I check in on
cuz like I look at Beyonce I see what
she's up to
I haven't seen Britney Spears I'm very
nervous what Amanda Bynes just got an
Instagram I saw what this morning what
okay coming up of all of our fingers
from running to check that out I just
got one today or yesterday madam I would
say I don't know I felt like I'm Radha I
don't know who that is I don't even know
how to pronounce her last name Emily
Ratajkowski oh oh yeah yeah yeah I
follow her which is kind of depressing
sometimes but I love checking on her
page and then
I don't know I I'm like kind of old
school but I kind of just look at my
friends doesn't know that's the nice
hell you have such a healthy
relationship with social media that's
it's bonkers
okay what's coming up in the future what
are the projects that you want to be
working on so mostly just my clothing
line
okay kind of like my main focus right
now um we are coming out with their Fall
collection next week cool just working a
lot on that yeah how how much in advance
do you have to prep for a collection to
come out pretty far so right now we
already have our Fall collection or
holiday collection and our spring
collection done you for 2020 spring 20
yeah so you have to project trends yeah
you think are gonna happen in 2020 yes
which is the hardest part that so you
basically are just like guessing and
checking yeah and like I hope this is
still cool in April when you get well be
it's the spring lines actually my
favorite and I'm super excited for it to
come up that's so cool
do you have any little tidbits of like
what we can expect for trends in 2020 so
I'm really into the puffy sleeves which
I feel like are right now but I also
don't think they're gonna go out of
style for a while cuz I heard well not
at least for me cuz I love them so um so
a a lot of stuff has you know the puffy
sleeve I have a lot of sets I have a lot
of really cute sweater is coming out for
fall which I'm excited about because I
love just throwing on they get cozy
sweater and it's our first time doing
nets so I'm excited for that yeah very
cool and this is all international right
or is it yes in the u.s. it's
international
okay yeah cool and really fun that's
super cool I can't imagine I to think
about like what could be popular in six
months from now I'm just like I'm gonna
still be wearing sweatpants and hoping
for the best so you working on the
clothing line yeah is there another book
in the works there's not no no it's a
one and done but it's so cool to be like
I have a book out there you know so I'm
like I'm so proud but I don't think yeah
not planning on writing another book
have you seen it while traveling have
you seen it like in airports have you
seen it like in bookstores like not yeah
not in the airport but we did see it
like it a couple of bookstores
especially the ones we were like signing
in and stuff
walking by it was like in the window so
that's cool that's cool that's the thing
your daughter's like can't deny yeah
that's super sweet okay we're gonna take
one last break I'm moving the fact we
have a bunch of Twitter questions for
you so we'll be right back good morning
to date is there something interfering
with your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your goals better help
online counseling can help they offer
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts lgbtq+ matters grief
self-esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment get the help
at your own time at your own pace
anything you share is confidential it's
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and if for some
reason you're not happy with your
counselor you can request a new one at
anytime for no additional charge and
best of all it's an affordable option
and you will get 10% off your first
month with the discount code grace go to
better help calm slash grace fill out
the questionnaire that helps them assess
your needs and get you matched with a
counselor that you will love today
that's better help calm slash grace if
you want to embellish your go-to outfits
and staple pieces with a new pair of
shoes without breaking the bank
check out ShoeDazzle every month
ShoeDazzle debuts a new selection of
exclusive and brand name shoes handbags
and more after taking a quick style quiz
you'll get your own custom online
showroom with items based on your own
personal style what a got-dang treat
shop there or browse the site freely to
find the perfect style for you
ShoeDazzle is for every woman whether
your style is classy edgy feminine or
glam check out as a guest or become a
VIP and get 30 to 50% off regular prices
plus free shipping on orders over $39
this site I guys as someone that doesn't
leave her house but wants to look like a
person
it leaves her house this has styled me
in a way that you can't believe here's
my personal experience with ShoeDazzle
you go online you take a quiz which
actually informs you so much more than
you even knew about what your personal
style preferences are they create an
actual like closet wardrobe for you that
makes you feel like a fancy-pants VIP
Beverly Hills Real Housewife and then
you order something for way less than
what you think it should be priced as
they send it to you it's great quality
and you look great in it I will say that
this is an actual like it's like the
beginning of clueless when she's like
looking through her actual like a
computer wardrobe and this actually
turns that into an actual delivery
service for you when you can't have that
kind of technology at home so highly
recommend get your first ShoeDazzle
style for as low as 10 dollars as a VIP
at ShoeDazzle comm slash grace that's
75% off your first item at ShoeDazzle
comm slash grace you also get free
shipping on orders over $39 and there's
no commitment when you purchase your
first order make sure you enter your
email address when you take the style
quiz to get exclusive discounts and the
inside scoop about new collections go to
ShoeDazzle dot-com slash Grace s h OE d
AZ z le comm slash grac e terms and
conditions apply amanda before we get
into these Twitter questions I want to
ask you the two questions ask every
single guest that is on the podcast and
first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
[Music]
gosh I know it's a very very tough
question it can be in most
it doesn't rebadow can be a joyous thing
be wonderful it's just your intention of
how you want to throw it but I love that
you're taking this question very serious
I don't know it's very kind of you we
can come back to it let's come back okay
we'll put a pin in that one Tiffany is
like everyone taking this question to
heart and I appreciate it
okay the other question I ask every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pants shooting story or close call but
you can only use three words or three
small phrases okay or a mixture some
mine for example is college jogging
front lawn okay
mine would be I love that you have one
this makes me happy my would be road
trip ex ex boyfriend
yeah I feel like that's been a lot of
people exact scenario I love how that
was a easier question for me than the
spaghetti one stumped you but you're
[ __ ] your pants at a gas station
with an ex-boyfriend immediate okay
someone let's get into these Twitter
questions someone is asking what's the
best moment that never made it to air um
I mean I would say probably what I told
you guys earlier just like the games
that we would play yeah and I think that
would have been really funny if it made
it to air but I also see why it wasn't
do you guys keep in touch with the
producers of the show yeah yeah not as
much I mean we're on the show you know
we're with them every day and then when
I talk to them after and then it kind of
slowly dies down a little but I still
keep in contact with all of them like
follow him on Instagram oh really I mean
because those must be yeah you're in
such sequestered areas then you guys
become close friends at that point yeah
so yeah I still talk to pretty much all
of them do usually did anyone ever try
to coerce a producer into using their
phone uh yeah actually so I like I don't
want to get anyone in trouble but when
I'm bachelor in paradise we had handlers
like us I named the producers and this
port handler I would always be like hey
can I borrow your phone and check my
Instagram she would let me and then
she got caught and I think she got in
big trouble and I felt so bad oh no
really really big trouble so but here's
hoping good karma comes back big sweet
sad but that's also a very funny thing
yeah you gotta check the gram yeah you
gotta say that's going on because what's
the I'm always curious about what the
actual timeline is on when you guys are
shooting bachelor in paradise and when
it goes on TV like are you guys still in
quote paradise when it's starting on
television no so we're home for over a
month almost okay yeah maybe like a
month and a half before it starts airing
gotcha
so you're not okay so it's not like oh
you are down there wondering how you
guys are coming across on television oh
gosh that would be make me anxious
oh but also I mean I have an anxiety by
proxy with you because I'm like the
existing and then hoping that they edit
you in a way no idea yeah kinda like
what they're gonna show cuz you're right
24/7 so like in between you getting off
the show and before airs you're like
rethinking every little thing for you
matters you may
oh my god remember when I did this are
they gonna show that but I would say
they don't they don't show obviously 90%
of what happens right now I know that's
a it's so curious to me it when they
show like GoPros and things like up in
the corners of the bedrooms yeah that
I'm like the bathroom situation must be
nuts so there are no cameras in the
bathrooms that's good yeah a little bit
of privacy but if you're in the bathroom
for too long they've been they get
curious and make sure that you're okay
yeah or the like stick a microphone you
just slowly see a microphone so actually
your your deck you're miked up all the
time so like even if you're going to the
bathroom like you know you're wondering
like positioning so do you wake up in
the morning they make you up immediately
immediately yeah Wow and so you're just
like is it weird to wear a bathing suit
now without a microphone a mic Packer
I mean I'm it's funny because we're so
used to having mics on and I actually
talked about it in my book that people
would jump in the ocean or the pool with
their microphones on all the time
because we would just forget yeah on
so and when you come back I'm sure that
there's like a little phantom like is
this still on me right now
I had like a scab on my back from where
it's yeah it's you're a badge of honor
okay so wants to know what's the
greatest meal you've ever had
um I am like such a foodie so I was like
everything so good to me but this is
gonna come off so weird but chick-fil-a
I think it's the best meal really ever
think of that's your favorite my
favorite it's so lame no I bet severe
it's popular for a reason because it's
delicious yeah what's your like least
favorite like least favorite fast food
or just food in general food in general
I don't really have I pretty much like
all food yeah that's great your least
favorite
my least favorite ooh um I would
probably I don't know why I came to my
mind but condiments like mustard I'm not
a big mustard person yeah I don't know
what it is I feel like mustard it's too
tangy
yeah okay no not ketchup yeah I'm like a
mayonnaise or a ranch person thank you
I'm also a mayonnaise person and I know
mayonnaise is very polarizing to a lot
of people I feel like whenever I mention
how much I love mayonnaise people will
be like you're disgusting yeah people
are just out buy it don't get it
like have you tried it recently oh gosh
I know it's the worst I might get my
fries in it yeah I agree yes it's the UH
it's been - I had a friend that went to
France and he was saying on his
honeymoon that like all week long he was
trying these french fries all week and
they had this like white dipping sauce
and he finally got the courage to ask
like a French waiter what is this and
the guy was like mayonnaise you've been
doing it in Venice for a week my friend
was hating me on it because I was eating
fries dipped in mayonnaise like all last
week when I was traveling she's like
that's so gross and I was like try it I
tried it and she's like okay it's
actually pretty good
it's basically like a baked potato with
sour cream yeah if you want to put it in
a different context okay someone to know
would you rather have a super strength
or super telekinesis ah super
telekinesis Oh
okay I think okay so I want to know best
and worst franchise kisser um I can't
think of any one that was a bad like
really bad kisser is it strange to watch
yourself kiss on television a little bit
yeah when they do like the clothes like
this yeah
and it lasts for a very long time yeah
yeah so it's a little weird um I can't
think of anyone that was like a bad
kisser how about best ah probably Josh
okay
that makes sense that makes sense yeah
okay chocolate vanilla or swirl in an
ice cream cone swirl swirl yeah best of
both worlds Red Lobster biscuits or
Olive Garden breadsticks Olive Garden
breadsticks because they've never had
Red Lobster biscuits cheddar Bay
biscuits oh my god they sell them now in
the grocery store uh treat you guys
you're gonna drive back to Orange County
after this stop a Red Lobster on the way
do yourself a favor uh and someone's
asking would you ever return to paradise
no no not would you ever go on any other
reality television show probably not no
no you're done I'm done
really yeah why I just it's not that I
like have anything against I just really
have no desire to do it again it was fun
and like I said I had a good experience
I made so many great friends any
opportunities came from it but it was
also just very exhausting and no matter
what reality TV show you're on there's
always drama it was just kind of a lot
for me to be involved in oh it seems so
tiring yeah and like I'm 29 and like I
can't I'm too tired for my mom I
shouldn't be spending my energy
elsewhere yeah do you have any advice
for the people that are coming up on
future seasons of bachelor bachelor in
paradise Bachelorette etc um I guess my
advice would be to I mean you know
you're gonna have good things said about
you and bad things mhm and not to react
too much to the bad things because they
blow over
my advice that's very sound advice yeah
have you had anyone any celebrity anyone
in entertainment follow you because of
this being on the show that has been
like surprising or shocking or wonderful
um not that I can think of I did I did
go to David Spade's house one time to
watch bachelor in paradise when he was
recording it so that was cool wait what
you just you said I don't think anyone
and then dropped a very specific but
when paradise was airing last year one
of my friends is mutual friends with him
and she was like he wants to invite you
over to watch bachelor in paradise
something like goddess we got to go to
his house and watch it with him so that
was really cool and is he a fan of the
show
like obviously she'll yeah so will were
his questions about like he must have
been super into all the drama in between
the drama he does I mean he just like
also thinks it's so funny with that yeah
I feel like the show attracts people
that are super fans because they
genuinely believe in everyone's journey
and everyone's you know potential shot
at love but then also because the
ridiculousness of how insane it is it's
just entertaining yeah it's great I mean
so if one of your daughter's audition
for this let's say 20 years from now
would you because this shows never gonna
stop it's gonna have 57 seasons of their
on what season twenty-something already
he's in 24 that's insane that sounds
like a parody of itself already it's
crazy
would you let your daughters go on this
show uh I just depends what they're like
at that age but I mean I wrote probably
I mean at that age they're gonna be in
their mid-20s I can't really say no do
what they want but what I want them to
not really yeah no I you've been there
done that
yeah yeah I've been to thank you so much
for being here of course before you go
every guest that's on the podcast we
have a personalized fortune cookie that
is made just for you yeah you're welcome
to open it and read the treasures that
are inside you
such a delicate way of opening this
circuit it's like I'm a trash compactor
please make sure oh yes okay this
podcast is way better than that Nik guys
he's lame grace is not my name is Amanda
and these are my original words yes Wow
I can't believe we got such a genuine
shout-out from Amanda not our pop guys
suck my dick Nick just kidding oh please
you can take the whole thing with you
this has been so wonderful thank you so
much where can people find you and the
book and everything that you're up to
and the clothing line if they don't
already know
so my Instagram is Amanda underscores
stand-in with two N's working on
changing that I was gonna ask ya I
didn't want to say I mean my clothing
line is Loni the label calm and my book
now accepting roses is available at all
book retailers amazing and the audio
book will be out you can listen to her
read the book and check out everything
she's up to because and also if you want
clothing to match your child and also
still look cool
yeah she's got that for you in spades
thank you guys for listening we'll see
you guys next time on episode of not too
deep goodbye too deep deep deep whatever
struggles you are facing from depression
and anxiety to trauma and grief better
help can connect you with a professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment it's convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapist anything you share is
completely confidential so get started
today it's an affordable option and
you'll get 10% off your first month with
the discount code grace by going to
better help calm slash Grace fill out a
questionnaire and get matched with a
counselor that you will love today not
too deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa Dumont's
writing by Diane Kang a production
assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]